[Music]
this is the highlight of a series of
ancient rituals that see Japanese
Emperor Naruhito ascend to the throne he
took over from his father who abdicated
in May and this ceremony makes it
official lucky me
I inherited an imperial status based on
Japanese constitutions as well as
Imperial Household law I hereby proclaim
to Japan and outside the country that I
have enthroned Prime Minister Shinzo Abe
a represented Japanese citizens
[Music]
exclaiming ban sign or long live the
Emperor three times
completing the ceremony 2,000 people
attended the once-in-a-generation event
including representatives from more than
180 countries the festivities were
scaled back in the wake of typhoon hagas
some japanese still lingered outside the
Imperial Palace it will be nice if the
new Empire will be as kind-hearted as
the former emperor and stay close to the
people a national poll suggests 70% hold
friendly or favorable views towards the
royal family despite debate over a law
that allows only men to become emperor
japan's royal dynasty goes back 2,000
years
this was the enthronement of nara hitos
grandfather in 1928 emperor hirohito he
was treated as a god and in his name
Japan entered World War two after its
defeat he renounced divinity and
subsequent Emperor's lost all their
political powers it's now a symbolic
role the next Emperor was akka hito seen
here in 1946 on his first day of high
school he spent his life working to
improve Japan's international relations
in May he became the first Japanese
monarch to abdicate in 200 years emperor
Nero hitos reign will be called raehwan
meaning order fortune and peace
charlotte Bellis al-jazeera